Spannend.
So, kann ich mal anmoderieren? Ja, brauchen wir eine Anmoderation oder können wir einfach rein starten? Das ist die Frage. Die Leute wissen mittlerweile schon, wie der Podcast heißt, die haben auch schon so eine grobe Ahnung davon, wie wir heißen. Aber das verstehe ich sowieso nicht, weil immer auch Wetten, dass wurde seit Jahren anmoderiert, bis zum Schluss wurde hat man gesagt, herzlich willkommen zu Wetten, dass. Ich meine, du stellst dich Personen auch nicht jedes Mal vor. Wenn ich morgen zur Arbeit komme, sage ich auch nicht so, hallo, guten Tag, mein Name ist Föhrmönchen Will, ich bin 26 Jahre alt.
Aber trotzdem hat sich eingebürgert, dass man im Laufe des Arbeitstages nochmal jedem Hallo sagt, dem man am Anfang morgen schon mal begegnet ist. Ja, das ist so die Frage, ne? Ich, unseren Praktikanten Max zum Beispiel, sage ich Moin zum Hallo, weil er immer rumturnt vorne und irgendwelche Kisten zusammenräumt.
Und dann sehe ich im Laufe des Tages nochmal Mittagessen, da grüsse ich jemanden auch.
Und ich denke mir immer, bin ich der Typ, der intern als der, der immer alle grüßt angesehen ist, oder ist das allgemeine Gepflogenheit? Ja, das ist ja immer so ein Showdown, das ist ja eine wilder Westensituation, wenn sich zwei Leute auf dem Flur begegnen. Man weiß nicht genau, was sind die Regeln, und lieber zieht man zuerst als zu spät und haut einfach mal eine Begrüßung raus, um dann nicht da treu zu sein. Ich habe immer so ein bisschen ein Problem mit Gruppenbegrüßungen. Angenommen, du kommst morgen ins Büro und irgendwie fünf Kollegen sitzen in der Kaffeeküche und du haust ein allgemeines Morgen rein. Zählt das schon wie eine einzelne individuelle Begrüßung, sodass du später nicht nochmal begrüßen musst oder musst du die, wenn du sie dann einzeln nochmal siehst, nochmal begrüßen? Es ist bei dir aber auch eine Besonderheit, weil du, sobald du den Raum betrittst, der Raum leise ist. Der Raum ist still.
Ja. Leute sehen, oh, der Protagonist, der große Florentin Will betritt den Raum, da ist erstmal allgemeines Schweigen angesagt und da ist so ein Betretenes auf den Tisch gucken.
Wo bei dir der Raum lauter wird, einfach um zu übertönen, dass du da bist, um deine generelle Lautst. Dein fucking John Williams Best of Medley, was einfach mit einer Lautstärke aus seinen Ohren dröhnt, dass man sich gar nicht mehr vorstellen kann, wie laut es in deinem Kopf sein muss. Ich denke mir manchmal auch so, wenn man so einen Sitcom-Charakter, der sich immer Mühe gibt, einen Auftritt zu haben. Beispiel, er installiert Boxen und einen Lichtkegel und er kommt morgens ins Büro und dann kommt ein Lichtscheinwerfer auf ihn und dann kommt Camina Burana oder so. Wäre ein lustiger Entrance für eine Sitcomfigur. Wenn du es im echten Leben machen würdest, würden die dich sofort abtransportieren. Du wärst sofort in einer Anstalt. Weil ich glaube, das kann es nicht übertragen. Ich würde auch gerne manchmal mehr Aufwand für einen Gag gehen und zum Beispiel nicht nur dieses andeuten, ich schütte einen Kaffee über deine Tastatur, sondern es wirklich machen.
Weil machen wir uns nicht zwei, wir verdienen in den Medien so viel, das kann man durchaus bezahlen, aber man macht es halt irgendwie nicht, man geht nicht mal ein bisschen weit für einen Gag. Ich schaue ja jede Woche dieselbe Serie an und weil ich darüber noch nicht genug spreche, Last September Monaco heisst dieser Podcast, aber da gibt es zum Beispiel eine Szene, wo sich zwei Figuren unterhalten und dann sagt einer eine Meinung, wie dieses Football-Team ist schlecht und dann kommt eine dritte Figur rein und sagt I couldn't agree more. Er kommt mit den Worten in das Gespräch vollkommen unbekannte Personen, die einfach reinkommt mit, ja da stimme ich dir zu. Meine Idee ist so ein bisschen, dass man so eine Situation zeigt, in der jemand so reinkommen will, aber es nicht passt, weil du musst ja schon, du kannst ja nicht zuhören so um die Eckecke, worüber die Reden und im richtigen Moment reinkommen. Das heißt, du musst schon aus 200 Meter Entfernung schnurstracks in die Konversation rein und entweder im letzten Moment mitnehmen, worum es geht oder halt wirklich schon mit einem, ja, das finde ich auch und alle gucken nicht, das passt gerade nicht, sorry, ich komme von 200 Metern, das war meine beste Chance, einmal in zehn funktioniert es, neunmal nicht. Stephans Talk-Tipp kommt nicht mit der Frage, hm, rein oder bitte, weil dann so ein Augenrollen du auslöst, wie so ein Domino-Effekt und dann alle nochmal gelangweilt, die eigentlich ganz coole Situation nochmal wiederholen. Ich habe schon oft in meinem Leben Anekdoten einfach vorzeitig beendet, weil ich sie siebenmal neu ansetzen musste. Du bist zur Hälfte durch, kommt eine neue Person rein und dann will man halt auch der anderen Person nicht unhöflich gegenüber sein und sagt dann, okay, damit sie mitreden kann, fasst man nochmal die vorigen 50% zusammen und dann kommt eine neue Person und dann muss man das wieder zusammenfassen. Du bist wie so eine Netflix-Serie, die immer sagt, was bis jetzt geschah, so ein kurzer Zusammenschnitt von den wichtigsten Eckpfeiern. Das ist wie der achte Transformers-Teil, wo man nochmal die ersten so ein bisschen anschneiden muss, für die Leute, die erst zum achten reinkommen. Aber irgendwann kann man sich nur noch erlauben, einfach einen Film zu machen, der einfach drauf scheißt. Und irgendwann höre ich einfach auf, da sage ich, nee Leute, ich habe keinen Bock mehr und dann gehe ich einfach, bevor die Pointe kam, weil wir sind uns alle klar, es kam eh keine Pointe. Apropos, es kam eh keine Pointe. Eure Epidemen sind da. Ja, wir haben zum großen App-Bdeen sind da.
Ja, wir haben zum großen App-Battle aufgerufen. Genau, richtig. Und wir haben mal ein bisschen die Social-Media-Profile, die wir alle haben, die fünfzehn, die ich forstet und guckt, wo kamen denn Ideen rein.
Karl Pediem schreibt uns.
Hat für mich jetzt schon gewonnen.
Hallo DPU. Ich habe eine tolle App-Idee. Es handelt sich um eine Fitness-App, in der man sportliche Aktivitäten wie Joggen oder Radfahren tracken kann, so weit so normal.
Das Hallo DPU, ich habe eine tolle App-Idee. Es handelt sich um eine Fitness-App, in der man sportliche Aktivitäten wie Joggen oder Radfahren tracken kann, so weit so normal. Das Besondere ist, dass man für absolvierte sportliche Aktivitäten Punkte bekommt, mit denen man sich seinen Charakter aufleveln kann. Gibt schon. Und anschließend gegen Freunde kämpfen kann, das wäre eine Supermitgliedsation. Gibt schon, next. Grüße, Karl. Next. Kurt schreibt eine App-Idee zum Thema Okay, der Name
des Absenders ist ein komplett anderer Name,
als der, mit dem er unterschrieben hat, deswegen sage ich
jetzt einfach mal den Fake-Namen, Kurt.
Und der schreibt, ihr kennt ja das Problem
mit Mittagsschlaf. Ja, klar.
Ihr kennt es doch bestimmt, wenn man einen Mittagsschlaf macht.
Ja, vor kurzem erst tatsächlich.
Aber ich habe nicht wirklich geschlafen, ich bin nur in so eine Art Hypnosedelirium verfallen. Und wäre auch alleine, glaube ich, nicht mehr rausgekommen. Ich werde einfach den Rest meines Lebens in diesem Schwebezustand gewesen, wo man nicht weiß, schlafe ich oder wache ich oder man ist so zwischendrin. Ich finde das Gefühl geil, vor Mittagsschlaf aufzustehen, weil du halt wie einen neuen Tag vor dir hast. Aber es dämmert schon draußen so ein bisschen und du bist schon ein bisschen, weil die Tage schon angebrochen, du gehst frisch in den Abend. Der schlimmste Teil des Tages ist der Anfang. Mittendrin ist gut und gegen Abend ist auch nochmal gut, aber der einzige Moment des Tages, den du nicht wiederholen willst, ist doch der Anfang. Es kommt auf den Anfang des Anfangs an, der ist scheiße, der Mittelteil des Anfangs ist mega gut, die Frühstückszeit super gut, wenn du gut geschlafen hast, aufgeschlafen bist. Also Kurt schreibt auf jeden Fall, ewig schläft, beim nächsten Mal stellt man einen 20-Minuten-Timer und schläft gar nicht, weil man denkt, dass der Wecker eh gleich klingelt, wenn man sich einen Timer stellt für den Mittagsschlaf. Deswegen meine Idee einer Apple Watch App Timer, man gibt zum Beispiel eine Zeit an, 15 Minuten, und der Pulsmesser der Watch erkennt, wann man schläft und dann startet erst der Timer.
Aber nicht schlecht. Finde ich eine gute Idee, Kurt.
Aber funktioniert das so wirklich, dass man
einen Puls hat und einen anderen Puls hat? Gute Frage, ich habe mir letztens auch
gedacht, dass man zum Beispiel
dass man vielleicht so Endorphine messen
könnte oder sowas und dann hörst du den ganzen
Tag Musik und dein
Endorphinmesser checkt, welche Musik dir gefallen
hat und speichert die in der Playlist. Aber gibt es
Endorphinmesser?
Gute. Gibt es die Prämisse, gibt es die Prämisse, auf der man eine ganze Idee aufbaut? Folgende Idee, Drachen, also, damit ihr sehen könnt, welche Drachen da oben über euch am Himmel fliegen, eine kleine App, dann fotografiert ihr das und schickt es uns ein und wir entscheiden dann, welche Drachen das waren. Ja, wie funktioniert die App? Ja, die letzte, die haben Apps so runter. Stimmt, gut, easy. Ja, also Endorphine sind ja im Gehirn und so, ich glaube, die kann man nicht so. Egal, forget it. Ja, okay, komm, hau die nächste raus jetzt. Es gibt ja auch diese Schlaf-Apps, die deinen Schlaf messen und die haben dann so Sensoren und die musst du auf dein Bett legen und die messen die Vibrationen und so. Ja, Bullshit, alles klappt. Wir lesen auch nicht alle Mails vor, weil wir haben zu viele bekommen. Und wir machen so ein bisschen das Moin-Moin-Prinzip, wir hauen so ein bisschen was aus dem Chat raus. Simon Rösel. Wir haben alle gelesen, die besten Hobbets raus. Ich schwöre dir, Simon Rösel, dein Name wird demnächst in einem Sketch vorkommen. Rösel, auch ohne dass ich diesen Namen gelesen hätte, Rösel wäre die nächstlogische Konsequenz gewesen. Keine schlechte Idee, wir brauchen für unsere Sketche bei guter Arbeit immer Namen. Ja, Namen sind immer scheiße. Wenn ihr euren Namen in guter Arbeit Sketchen haben wollt, überweist uns einfach 10 Euro auf patreon.com. Schickt uns einfach euren Namen und dann bauen wir ihn ein. Ich habe seitdem ich gelernt habe, dass Hugo Ergon Balder diesen Tipp verraten, dass man nur Umlaute in Nachnamen benutzen soll, weil das immer lustig klingt. Und seit dem achten Mal drauf heißissen alle Hybi, Hyma, alle heißen so, bald Rösel. Aber tatsächlich, der war ja in die unwahrscheinlichen Ereignisse zu Gast in unserer kleinen SNL-Show. Klar, klein, betonlicht auch klein. Und war, und auch auf Vergangenheit liegt vor allem die Betonung. Und da ging es darum, dass es einen kleinen Sketch gab mit einer Puppe, die sich übergeben hat. Also eine Puppe, eine Handpuppe.
Alter, die härteste Diskussion meines Lebens, die ich jemals geführt habe.
Ja, ganz kurz, lassen wir kurz die Prämisse starten.
Also eine Handspielerpuppe und der Gag war sozusagen, dass die Puppe selbst nervös ist vor dem Auftritt und dann immer wieder kotzt während dem Auftritt, weil sie so nervös ist.
So, das war der Gag.
So, wie heißt diese Puppe dann?
In dem ursprünglichen Skript, das unser netter Kollege Sami Challa damals geschrieben hat, hieß diese Figur Frank Schneider. Also die Puppe hieß Frank Schneider. So, und dann irgendwann hat er die umbenennen wollen, oder? Gehe ich recht in der Name? Ja, Hugo Egon Balder meinte den klassischen Show bis in Schneider, machte Namen mit Umlauten sind immer lustig, sagte Hugo Egon Balder. Und dann hat Egon den umbenannt von Fischer in Göbel. Ja, so. Frank Göbel. So, und du hast die Diskussion geführt, weil du Fischer so großartig fandest. Schneider, Frank Schneider. Frank Schneider so großartig fandest. Ich habe die Diskussion aus einem anderen Grund ebenso emotional geführt gegen Göbel, weil Göbel in einer anderen Sprache in einem einem gewissen Dialekt, Kotzen heißt.
Ah ja, Göbel, ne? Genau. Und diese Puppe, das war der Gag, hat sich die ganze Zeit übergeben. Und im Moment, wo die Göbel heißt, macht die den Gag kaputt, weil es erwartbar ist und weil das plötzlich einen komischen Konflikt in dem Kopf auslöst, der dem Gag im Wege steht. Und ich habe diese so hart wie noch nie in Diskussionen geführt, weil ich mich so gegen Göbel ausgesprochen habe. Und du, weil du einfach Schneider so cool fandest. Ja, aber ich fand die Vor fand die Vorstellung so lustig, dass du deine Handpuppe Frank Schneider nennst. Also so, jede Handpuppe heißt irgendwie Flaumy oder Pfiffy oder Fluffy oder Schmibi, aber keine Handpuppe heißt einfach Frank Schneider. Und genau da, das ist eine Diskussion, die führen wir, glaube ich, jeden zweiten Tag, dass man in Sketchen auch Elemente braucht, die bewusst nicht lustig sind, damit andere Gags, meistens die der nachfolgenden, besser wirken. Beispiel, du machst eine Nachrichtensendung, wo am Ende irgendwas Ungewöhnliches passiert. Das heißt, du hast erstmal die Nachrichtensendung, etablierst das Setting und dann kann was Lustiges passieren und du denkst dir, das ist ja lustig, weil das ja in einem ernsten Nachrichtensetting stattfindet. Aber ich finde es so gut, dass wir beide einer Meinung waren, aus komplett unterschiedlichen Gründen. Ja, aber das ist ganz nett. Das beschreibt einen nicht ganz gut, wie wir funktionieren. Wir kommen zum Beispiel in Ergebnissen, aber aus ganz verschiedenen Richtungen. Ja, aber da ist bei uns oft die Diskussion, ob man dann den Weg zum Gag auch noch lustig machen soll, oder ob man dann nicht den grossen Gag am Ende verrät. Wollen wir mal irgendwann in diesem Podcast die ersten Skriptideen mal vorstellen? Vielleicht so eine Nerd-Folge, so eine gute Arbeit Nerd-Folge, Insider-Folge, wo wir mal erste Skriptentwürfe vorlesen vielleicht und dann, wie es nachher geworden ist. Boah, ich weiß nicht, ob das interessant ist, aber... Alles klar, bei Simon Rösel schlägt vor, hey ihr beiden, mein App-Idee, Ungrammerly, bist du auch von deiner glatt gebügelten Social-Media-Präsenz genervt? Ungrammarly baut dir ein paar kühle, moderne Fehler in deinen Switchers, Posts und Snaps ein und macht dein Präsent echt edgy. Alles klar. Was? Der will, dass man Rechtschreibfehler automatisch einbaut in Posts oder was? Ja. Bullshit. Die Community Podcast Show. Kevin Verbel blink. Lebt mir nur den Vornamen vor. Vielleicht wollte er nicht genannt werden. Das stimmt. Kevin. Hey, Leute, hier meine geniale App-Idee. Münzen. Was soll dieser Unflug? Wer braucht doch dieses nervige Hartgeld? Die meisten halbwegs intelligenten Menschen mich und sicherlich euch angeschlossen werfen, tagtäglich den unnötigen Ballast in Form von Kupfer, Messing und Nickel am Ende des Tages eine große Sparbüchse. Alternativ Umschlag, kann ich mir noch empfehlen. Doch was passiert, wenn nun Not am Mann ist? Das Monatsende naht und das Handy hat eine Spider-App und dringend werden diese Moneten benötigt. Was ist denn ein Spider? Eine Spider-App ist, wenn dein Handy gesprungen ist vorne. Ah ja, okay, sorry, okay, ich bin zu langsam. Das ist ein bisschen dumm. Die Frage, die sich nun hier stellt, ist, wie viel habe ich eigentlich in diesem blödsinnigen, schweinchenförmigen Behältnis? Nachzählen dauert zu ewig und ist langweilig. Die ganze Dose mitnehmen, unterwegs verpassen, klippert seltsam, jetzt kann Abhilfe geschaffen werden, einfach die neue App installieren. Fotokröten, mit Fotokröten schießt ihr ein Bildchen von eurem vor euch ausgebreiteten Kleingeld und erhaltet sofort das Wissen über den genauen Betrag eures Kleinvermögens. Moment, dann musst du das aber alles zweidimensional vor dir ganz weit ausbreiten über den Fussboden, weil sonst weißt du ja nicht, wie hoch der Haufen ist. Ich finde aber das Konzept, man macht ein Foto und über das Foto sagt es einem Dinge interessant. Ja. So, wenn ich ein Foto von dir mache, weil es gibt ja auch zum Beispiel, es ist ja wissenschaftlich belegt, Schönheit ist ja belegt, also Wissenschaft ist ja empirisch untersucht, genau, es ist ja dekodiert einfach. Man kann sagen, man kann schöne Menschen messen, in dem Teile des Gesichts asymmetrisch sind, manche sind symmetrisch, manche sind grösser, manche sind kleiner. Es gibt diesen Default-Schönheitskopf, der furchtbar hässlich ist aus irgendeinem Grund, weil sich jemand vertan hat vielleicht. Und das wäre doch mal interessant, dass ich die fotografiere und die App sagt mir, ob du attraktiv bist, theoretisch. Wenn ich nämlich ein Mädchen vor sehe und ich nicht weiß. Sag bitte Frauen. Frauen, kleine Mädels vor mir sehe und mir denke so, okay, ich will sie ausstellen, ich will sie exponiert neben mir hertragen, ich will, dass die Gesellschaft mich als jemanden wahrnimmt, der die attraktivste Frau der Welt hat. Fotografiere die Frau und die sagt mir, so finden andere Menschen die prozentual attraktiv. So wie in Black Mirror, wo du immer genau, wo dir jemand so deinen Berater sagen kann, wie sich das auf deinen Social Media Wert auswirken kann. Aber die Idee finde ich nicht schlecht, dass du was fotografierst, zum Beispiel du fotografierst dein Bücherregal und dann analysiert das Foto und sagt, wie viel du hast. Und es sagt dir, wie pretentious du bist. Ja, genau. Böll, alles klar. Noch eingeschweißt, Idiot. Die Laura hat uns eine App-Idee geschickt, und zwar Netflinder, eine sympathische Netflixer, finde sympathische Netflixer in einer Nachbarschaft. Anscheinend ist es eine Mischung aus Tinder und Netflix, so dass man danach suchen kann, wer gerade welche Serie in seiner Umgebung anschaut. Auch gerade guckt, supergut. Und wenn man gerade in derselben Staffel der Folge ist, dann kann man sich hier direkt treffen und zusammen Netflix anschauen und so vielleicht die Liebe seines Lebens finden. Finde ich keine schlechte Idee, Laura. Finde ich super. Finde ich wirklich eine gute Idee. Gero schreibt uns, jeder hasst Wecker und Wecker-Geräusche. Nun kommt Becker-Rendo ins Spiel. Ausschlafen.de Ja, aber das Problem kann ich gar nicht verstehen, so dieses man überhört seinen Wecker, wenn man sich an den Ton gewöhnt. Ganz einfacher Lifehack. Das ist nicht die Prämisse, das nervt. Aber ganz einfacher Lifehack an der Stelle, einfach seinen normalen Handy-Klingelton als Wecker-Ton benutzen. Du wirst immer davon aufwachen, wenn du denkst, du wirst angerufen. Ganz einfach. Okay, aber irgendwann ist das ja primär dein Weckton und du wachst einfach auf im Büro, wenn du angerufen wirst. Wie oft wirst du in der Woche angerufen? Ja, nicht so häufig. Wie oft? Sag mal eine Zahl. In Zentimetern. Fünf, sechs Mal pro Woche. Pro Woche? Also ungefähr einmal am Tag? Ja, ungefähr. Puh, ich werde einmal in der Woche angerufen vielleicht. Würdest du gerne mehr angerufen werden? Eigentlich nicht, ich werde sehr ungern angerufen. Naja, gut. Was hast du eigentlich für einen Klingelton? Komm, wir checken mal ein paar Sachen. Ich habe gar keinen Klingelton, ich habe Mondmodus, wüsste mich nicht erreichen. Frederik schreibt uns den fantastischen App-Idee. Für alle Hipster und Retro-Konservativisten da draußen hat er eine Idee, das 4 zu 3-Format wieder groß zu machen. Und zwar kann man alle Filme in 4 zu 3 anschauen, wenn man sich dafür interessiert, dass sie konservativ und Retro-Hipster sind. Apropos Retro-Hipster, Stefan ist großer Fan von La La Land. Wollen wir mal ein bisschen in die Filmkritik-Ecke vorsto inzwischen war ich auf dem Klo auf der Herrentoilette und die gesamte Herrentoilette hat komplett einstimmig City of Stars gepfiffen. Und das war so ein Moment, wo wir alle so, ja. Denn das will Jazz doch, Jazz vor allem, will gesungen werden, nachgepfiffen werden auf dem Klo, denn dafür ist Jazz bekannt, dass man es einfach nachsingen kann, wo auch schon meine erste Kritik wäre, es ist kein Jazzfilm. Aber auf der anderen Seite, du willst mich jetzt darstellen als jemanden, der La La Land liebt, was ich ein bisschen gemein finde, weil das habe ich nie gesagt. Ich habe ihm gesagt, es ist für mich ein guter Film, besser bestimmt als du ihn wahrgenommen hast, aber für mich hat er auch viele, viele Flaws, die es sich mal anzusprechen lohnt. von Florentin. Ja, wirklich, ich weiss es gar nicht. Nee, willst du nicht? Du hast nicht viel Merke aufgemacht.
Ja, keine Ahnung, sorry, es war vielleicht... Impuls, Impuls!
Man ist immer so gefangen in so einer Erwartungshaltung, man geht eine große Erwartung rein, dann findet man ihn vielleicht eher so mittel, und dann sagt man, okay, würde ich ihn vielleicht gut finden, wenn ich nicht die Erwartung gehabt hätte, dann möchte man auch nicht der sein, der gegen den Strom schwimmt. Aber mal ganz kurz, Ryan Gosling ist einer der besten Comedy-Darsteller auf dieser Scheißwelt. Der hat so ein gutes Timing, der ist einfach der unterschätzteste Comedy, rein Comedy-Darsteller. Ich finde, der ist so lustig, der spielt so, so lustig. Mal gucken, euch mal von The Nice Guys, auch ein lustiger Film, guckt euch da mal vielleicht die B-Roll an bei YouTube. Jeder Take von dem ist echt lachenswert. Also wirklich, finde ich schon. Ja, auf jeden Fall ein guter Mann. Ich weiß nicht einem Film generell, um es ganz kurz zu machen, so ein bisschen dieses konstante Selbst-auf-die-Schulter-Klopfen gestört. Oder selbst auf die Schippe nehmen, man weiß es nicht. Ich glaube, wir sind Menschen, die Ironie sehr gewohnt sind. Deswegen gehen wir in so einen Film und denken so, war das jetzt ernst gemeint? Weil ich meine, da gab es Szenen drin, die teilweise wirklich merkwürdig waren. Szenen, in denen bemängelt wird, dass Jazz nur im Hintergrund gespielt wird und in der Szene wird Jazz im Hintergrund gespielt, wo wir sagen, guter Gag. Offensichtlich ein Gag, was da nicht so präsentiert. Ja, man weiß es nicht genau. Und dann immer so dieses Ja, so gehört es. Und ich weiß zum Beispiel jetzt im Vergleich zu Whiplash ging es ja auch irgendwo um Jazz, aber da hat man irgendwie gesagt so, da hat die Hauptfigur nie gesagt, Jazz ist das Beste der Welt, so, da gibt es ja auch die Szene mit der Freundin, wo dann zum zum Beispiel sagt, ja, Jazz ist nicht für jeden so, keine Ahnung, ich finde es cool. Aber irgendwie, wo es zum Konzert geht, meint er auch so, ja, das ist nicht was für jeden. Cool, aber es ist sein Ding, seine persönliche Leidenschaft, er geht da rein. Aber Ryan Gosling ist so dieser scheiß, dieser abgehobene Typ, der sagt so, nein, das darf man nicht und so und so. Mich nerven Filme, die kritisieren, was sie selber sind. La La Land ist so ein Film und ich finde, World ist auch so ein Film. Aber man weiss nicht, ob sie das kritisieren oder ob sie es selber auch die ganze Zeit sind. Doch, auf jeden Fall. Und Jurassic World kritisiert, erst mal, der Film kritisiert durch diesen Schwarzen, der am Ende in der Band spielt und der sagt, man muss immer nach vorne gehen, man muss immer nach vorne gucken, man muss es ein bisschen remixen so. Und der Film kritisiert diesen Charakter ja, aber der Film ist ja nichts anderes als dieser Charakter, weil er remixt ja nur alt, dagewesene Dinge, neu und macht sie populär, Popkultur einfach. Und Jurassic World macht genau das gleiche. Jurassic World kritisiert die ganze Zeit dieses, wow, es muss immer größer werden, wir müssen immer neu, es muss immer unnatürlicher werden. Die Leute wollen immer mehr, kritisieren diese Konsumlust und diesen Konsumfokus und kritisieren, dass diese grosse Dino immer größer, immer größer sein muss. Aber der Film ist nichts anderes als immer mehr, immer mehr, immer größer. Ja, aber vielleicht ist das die falsche Blickweise. Ich meine, La La Land ist für mich einfach so konsumierbare Arroganz. Du kannst einfach Arroganz genießen, ohne sie selbst leben zu müssen. Kein Mensch, der einen Film gesehen hat, wird danach jetzt anfangen, die grossen Jazz-Klassiker zu hören, so wie es die Figur von Ryan Gosling getan hätte. Niemand. Es ist einfach nur Konsumierung. Du kannst dich für den Zeitraum dieses Films so fühlen, als hättest du richtig Ahnung von irgendwas. Du bist mega sophisticated und ja, stimmt. Wow, plötzlich mag ich Jazz. Aber da hört man, Jazz und Jazz ist gar nicht das, was da gesungen wurde. Im Film kommt ja auch so gut wie kein Jazz vor. Die meisten Musikstücke sind ja a, sehr poppig und b, auch wirklich das, was Jazz ausmacht, irgendwie dieses bisschen weniger Wiederholung, irgendwie so ein bisschen abgespaced, irgendwie so unprevisatorisch, exzentrisches. Das ist alles so ganz klar, drei, vier Akkorde, bla, bla, bla, ganz klassisch. Es sind gute drei Lieder für Musical auch ein bisschen zu wenig. Lass mal kurz weitermachen mit App-Ideen. Auf jeden Fall. Das war die Filmkritik-Runde. Und zwar eine sehr gute Idee, wie ich finde, eine Einkaufs-Listen-App, die sich je nachdem, in welchem Markt du bist, neu sortiert. Nach dem Markt. So, du schreibst Milch bis im Rewe, der weiß in Reven, Reves, plötzlich ist die Milch weiter hinten und sortiert dementsprechend die Mail, die Liste um, je nachdem, wo du gerade stehst. Finde ich super. Finde ich richtig gut. Ach, der zeigt dir dann auch direkt an, wo im Supermarkt die Milch ist. Ja, genau. Vielleicht, also einfach, dass die Liste sich sortiert, je nachdem, wo du gerade stehst. Finde ich super. Ach, der zeigt ja dann auch direkt an, wo im Supermarkt die Milch ist. Ja genau, vielleicht, also einfach, dass die Liste sich sortiert, je nachdem, wo du gerade kommst. Puh, das stelle ich mir sehr anspruchsvoll vor. Zu programmieren, ja, sicherlich. Sehr gut finde ich die Idee von Felix, der schreibt sehr geehrtes UFO, wie wäre es mit einem Media Player, der einen unendlich skalierbaren Lautstärkeregler hat. Mich stört es schon seit geraumer Zeit, dass bei den meisten Lautstärke-Reglern irgendwann ein Punkt erreicht ist, an dem einfach Schluss ist. Gerade wenn man das Podcast-Ufo mit Stefan Kitzler und Florian Will hören möchte, ist dieser Punkt leider oft viel zu früh erreicht. Nur das Intro, welches ihr in frühen Folgen genutzt habt, jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr, hat mir regelmäßig das Trommelfell weggelassen, schön mal so in die Gedankenwelt von so einem Hörer reinzugehen, der so mit dem Tommel weggeblasen ist, ein bisschen skeptisch vor unserem Projekt steht, so ein bisschen nicht verschabter, viel nicht verstanden. Probleme wie lautes Knäckebrot essen, die laute Baustelle nebenan oder das leise Bomen meines Kühlschrankes könnte so zum Problem der Vergangenheit werden. Du kannst auch dich vom Kühlschrank entfernen übrigens, das ist auch eine Idee, die ich letztens gefunden habe. Um zu verhindern, dass kurzzeitig jede Momente... Die du gefunden hast. Laute Momente. Fett, fett, fett, fett. Dein Gehirn wegpusten, könnte man noch eine Einstellung hinzufügen, die jedes Geräusch, welcher in der Audiodatei enthalten ist, auf die exakt gleiche Lautstärke skediert wird. Schluss mit laut und leise. Das ist eine ganz geile Idee. Ist aber auch tatsächlich so, ich habe zum Beispiel auch bei Podcastschnittprogrammen, habe ich teilweise auch so Regler, wo man die Lautstärke einstellen kann und dann sage ich so la lauter, und dann bin ich auf Maximum und sage ich, ja, aber noch laut, und es geht schlicht. Ja, genau. Aber es muss doch technisch möglich sein. Natürlich, du kannst einfach plus Dezibel so. Aber kennst du das, dass du dich lauter hörst? Mit manchen, früher hatte ich das, dass ich an meinen ersten Indiekopfhörer, und irgendwann war das mit zu laut, war mit zu laut, aber dann gewöhnt man sich langsam daran und irgendwann wird man immer lauter. und ich hasse Kopfhörer, wo du die auf maximaler Lautstärke hören musst. Weil die sind für mich, für mich denke ich mir, ich habe die Grenze erreicht jetzt. Das war es mit uns beiden. Man kann nicht mehr lauter machen, man hört mal irgendwann schlechter, man kann nicht mehr lauter machen. Ich verachte diese Hörer plötzlich. Und das ist auch plötzlich ganz rot, da hat man diese roten Striche. Richtig, ich wollte gerade sagen, bei einem Betriebssystem wurde bei der Lautstärke, das sind so verschiedene Punkte, so 20 Punkte, glaube ich. Und ab der Mitte werden die Punkte gelb und dann werden sie rot und dann steht es sehr lauter. Und das hat mir tatsächlich, das ist eines der besten Updates ever, weil ich tatsächlich immer runterregel und dadurch vielleicht mein Gehör a nicht so schnell verliere und b vielleicht auch ein bisschen feiner anpasse, dass wenn man immer nur leise Musik hört, das irgendwie vielleicht ein bisschen konditioniert wird. Psychologisch schwierig, ich bin bei einem roten Strich, es steht schon sehr laut da. Du bist ein Dealbreaker, Stefan, du musst ein Regelbuch nur krumm angucken und es bricht im Schlamm aus. Und es landet im Müll. Also ganz kurz mal eben, das ist aber dumm von mir, weil überleg mal, ich würde die ganze Zeit denken, ich höre nicht laut Musik, wenn ich auf dem letzten Gelben bleiben würde. Ich mache mal einen noch mehr, das ist wie, man will sich von Zug schmeißen, geht aber nur den einen Schritt hinter diese Linie. Ja, naja. Keiner Lifehack an der Stelle, einfach mal euch konditionieren und zwar im Alltag einfach immer mal wieder die Lautstärke ein Stück runterstellen. Oder ein bisschen hochstellen. Nee, runter bitte. Einfach mal mehr Fett essen. Nee, weniger. Nein, nein, ihr könnt euch konditionieren in beide Richtungen. Ja, ja, ich weiß. Nein, nein, nein, weniger. Nur zum Beispiel, der Unterschied zwischen jetzt, ob du jetzt auf Lautstärke 15 oder 14 bist, hörst du so gut wie nicht. Geht auch auf 16 oder 18. Naja, oder auf 14 runter halt so. Zum Beispiel habe ich mich konditioniert, immer wenn ich auf die Uhr schaue, auf meinem Handy, dann habe ich auch gleichzeitig den Reflex, die Lautstärke einen Punkt runterzumachen. Und wenn du das über den Tag verteilt, du schaust so alle halbe Stunde auf die Uhr, dann hörst du am Ende des Tages gar nichts mehr. Nee, aber dann denkst du dir immer, oft denkst du einfach, nee, jetzt grad nicht, Alter. So, aber oft schon. Und dadurch schaffe ich es im Laufe des Tages, es immer so ein bisschen runter zu skalieren und es auch an die Umwelt anzupassen. Dass wenn ich jetzt in den Zug einsteige und es da nicht mehr so laut ist, ich automatisch mich irgendwie über die erste Stunde des Zugfahrts wieder runterpegel auf den Pegel, der in Ordnung ist und jetzt nicht die gesamte Zugfahrt mit zu lauter Lautstärke fahren. Lifehack! Ich habe beim Autofahren neulich einen ganz komischen Bug gehabt in meinem iPhone, und zwar immer, wenn ich mein Handy hochgenommen habe, ist ein Punkt leiser geworden beim Autofahren. Ich hätte halt mein Handy angeschlossen an mein Radio, hab laut Musik gehört, bin laut durch Lehm miserabel über die Autobahn, über die A1 gesaust. City of Stars! Aber wenn man von außen auf mein Auto guckt, ist einfach so, man hört den Bass von so einem komischen Musical-Song.
Und dann habe ich halt sehr laut gehabt und dann, nur wenn ich mein Handy hochgenommen habe, ist ein Lautstärke leiser geworden.
Was ein seltsamer Bug.
Unfassbar.
Und dann habe ich den immer wieder lauter gemacht und habe mein Leben und dass viele andere Autofahrer, auch diese kleinen Twingos von der Autobahn abgedrängt, einfach weil ich kurz mal meine Hände wieder lauter machen muss.
Ich glaube, für Twingos kriegt man auch Bonuspunkte, wenn man die zu einem Unfall treibt, da kriegt man einfach Bonuspunkte. Kennst du das Spiel, dass man sich schlägt, wenn man Twingo sieht? Nee. Twingo, haut man jemanden, ruft Twingo. Ehrlich gesagt, ich weiss nicht mal genau, wie ein Twingo aussieht. So wenig Ahnung habe ich von. Ein Kastenwerk. Ich bin ja eher so der Literaturfreak. Patrick oder Patrick oder Steffen. Ich glaube, uns hören mehr Patricks als Patricks. Ja, das glaube ich auch.
Ich finde auch, Patrick, tut mir leid.
Patricks sind minderwertiger als Patricks.
Ja, ich habe was in dem.
Silence, die App, die Ruhe und Stille
verbreitet. Der Nutzer hat entweder die Chance,
eine der vorgegebenen stille Samples
zu benutzen, zum Beispiel still im Wald
oder stille auf dem Berg, oder selber
einen stillen Moment, der dem die Nutzer,
der die Nutzerin gerade gefällt, aufzunehmen. In den bereitgestellten Samples ist natürlich wichtig, dass sämtliche Geräusche rausgefiltert werden. Es wird kein Möwengeschrei, Wellengang oder das sanfte Geräusch eines fallenden Baumes im Wald zu hören sein, ich glaube, dass diese App vielen Menschen dem Alltag helfen könnte. Wer kennt das nicht? Die erländerziehende Mutter muss sich gerade um einen gleichzeitig drehen und reden können. Es kommt sehr viel Erklärung, sehr viel Preise, sehr viel Vertriebsideen, sehr viel einen Website-Entwurf, wow. Alles klar. Habe ich nicht ganz verstanden. Ich glaube einfach nur, war ein bisschen eine Scherzidee, ne? War eine kleine fiese Scherzidee. Ja. Guck dir mit bitterbösem Gesicht, die Stirn in Falten, bisschen säuerlich, guck dir einen an. Ich habe keine Apps mehr. Ich fand die Netflix-Idee super. Ich fand die Lautstärke-Idee am besten. Dass man so eine App installiert und dann hat man einfach unendlich Hochlautstärke. Aber das geht nicht, das ist per se nicht möglich. Hä, sagt wer? So, dein Handy-Lautsprecher sagt irgendwann nein. Er sagt irgendwann, wenn du da noch einmal draufdrückst, sagst du, ne, ich bin jetzt einfach im Arsch, du kannst mich nicht noch lauter machen. Handy-Lautsprecher haben Grenzen. Die haben doch nur einen gewissen Raum zu schwingen. Aber die Handy-Lautstärke ist doch in Relation zu der Musikstück-Lautstärke. Wenn ein Musikstück... Alles klar. Struggle im Alltag. Hey! Oh, Alter. Oh, Alter. Alles, was du jetzt sagst. Scheissegal, du hättest gerade irgendwie die Weltformel lösen können, wenn währenddessen das Mikrofon ins Gesicht fällt, vor allem so unglücklich. Bisschen unglücklich. Oh Mann, jetzt überbrückt mal Mr. Masterclass, Moderatoren Masterclass, jetzt mach mal. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, apropos Struggle, das Projekt ist kurz vorm Ende, sage ich euch ganz ehrlich, finanziell habe ich das Projekt ruiniert, habt ihr vielleicht auch Twitter verfolgt, PayPal. Und PayPal ist halt ein bisschen Arschloch, wenn man alles verkackt, wenn man zum Beispiel, wenn man, also ich habe, ach, das ist so eine Reihe von Verkettungen, die da passiert ist, also wir haben massiv viel Geld auf dem Konto, dann kam jetzt offensichtlich eine Mail, das wird zu viel, das wird zu viel, noch nicht genug, patreon.com, also nur, ne, patreon, also wir haben zu viel Geld auf dem Konto, Paypal wird uns das in den Haaren zugedreht, hat das Konto eingefroren, wir kommen aber nicht rein, weil wir den Login vergessen haben. Jetzt hat sich so eine Art Quest-Reihe entwickelt, wie man das eigentlich nur aus Videospielen kennt. Und zwar folgendes. Ich muss, um den Namen zu ändern, muss ich, ne, also um das Geld zu kommen, muss ich das Passwort ändern. Um das Passwort zu ändern, muss ich den Namen ändern. Um den Namen zu ändern, muss ich denen einen Kontoauszug und einen Personalausweis schicken. Um denen einen Kontoauszug zu schicken, muss ich meine Karte freischalten, die meine Kontoauszüge erstellt. Offensichtlich ist meine Karte für Kontoauszüge gesperrt. Keine Chance, es hat sich eine Reihe an Dingen gebildet, die es gerade uns unmöglich machen, überhaupt an Geld zu kommen. Ja, das ist das, wenn du das Problem nicht eingeleitet hättest mit, wir haben zu viel Geld, könnte es vielleicht eine sympathische Anekdote geworden werden, aber so einfach nicht. So denkt man sich einfach, ja. Wie jetzt du es formuliert? Ich hätte einfach gesagt, wir haben Probleme mit PayPal, weil du hast eine Account erstellt und du hast deine Handynummer angegeben, Handynummer eigentlich eine der wenigen Nummern, die man perfekt auswendig kann, so sagen wir mal so zwölf Stellen. Ich kann sie zu gut auswendig. Wie viele davon hast du falsch eingegeben von zwölf Stellen? Pass auf, ich habe bei PayPal angerufen und dann hat er gesagt, ja, ich darf Ihnen nicht verraten, wo die Fehler passiert sind, aber ich kann Ihnen Folgendes verraten, die Nummer, die hier hinterlegt ist, ist der Nummer, von der Sie gerade anrufen, nicht unähnlich und hat dann gesagt, es ist ein Sie vollidiot, es sind ein paar Fehler unterlaufen. Wie kann man denn bei einer Handy-Nummer mehr als ein Fehler machen? Nee, ich habe wahrscheinlich nur einen Fehler gemacht, das ist egal. Auch mit einem Fehler kommt man nicht durch. Was ist das für ein Vorwurf? Ist das das Zitat von Stefan Titzel, mit einem Fehler kommt man nicht durch? Soll das jetzt unser neues Podcast-Ufo-T-Shirt werden? Wenn du einen Fehler... Ap Apropos neue Shirts ab März. Nein, Könige noch nicht. Jetzt haben wir mindestens den Druck ein bisschen. Wenn wir es schaffen, bei Patreon über 500 Euro zu kommen, dann haben wir noch ein paar Podcast-Ufo-Designs raus. Oh Mann, ey. Leute, wir haben, ey, sorry, wir haben, als wir damals, wir dachten ehrlich gesagt, dass die T-Shirts ein bisschen besser laufen. Deswegen haben wir damals gleich 500 Exemplare gekauft, davon sind jetzt noch so ungefähr 480 übrig. Also, wir haben leider unsere, unsere Lagerkapazitäten sind leider ausgeschöpft. Wir haben einen Raum angemietet, der ist voll mit Zeug, mit Müll, auch viel Müll, viele Pfandflaschen. Wir haben so ein WG-Zimmer gemietet, sind da aber nie eingezogen, sondern haben da nur unsere T-Shirts hingestellt. Mittlerweile wurden da ein paar
Obdachlose drin, ist okay, wir haben es mal gelassen.
Wir sind sehr gut gekleidet übrigens. Das Ding ist, irgendwann
dachte ich mal, uns gehen die Themen aus.
Aber dann habe ich gemerkt,
dass wir uns selber
immer wieder Themen erstellen
und wir in so einer selbstreferentiellen
Spirale gefallen sind, weil wir
jede Woche Dinge aufdröseln müssen, die wir
verkackt haben innerhalb der Woche. Der Strudel der Selbstreferenz, Renz, Renz, Renz, diese Woche eine neue Ausgabe. Die Puffopedia ist zurück! Yes! Und wurde wieder von Bots überran, aber jetzt ist sie wieder zurück! Es ist unfassbar, es ist mit Hilfe des Community-MVPs, lass mich kurz den Namen schauen. Statistisch am häufigsten ist Daniel. Ganz kurz Daniel Müller, wie eine gute Statistik. Leider falsch und linke Klick. An der Stelle ... Überwirkung ist die Däne. Ich kann mich noch gut an sein Bild erinnern, aber ich kann nicht genau ... Wie sah er denn aus? Beschreib ihn doch mal vielleicht. Wie lange kann man in dieser Stimmung bleiben? Das ist die Frage. Merkst du, wir sind so ein bisschen wie in so einer Kirmes-Mechanik gefangen. Was, wo ist der denn, ach fuck ey, das war... Beschreib ihn vielleicht mal, wie er aussieht. Alles noch mal raus. Nein, er hat ein Hemd an. Nein, ich steige die Folgen nicht mehr. Wie war es dein Wochenende denn so, na ja, ging so, warum denn nicht so gut und wie sah war ein bisschen... Sorry, Slade. Aber es ist momentan mit einem Community-MVP, kann man auch schon mal direkt eine neue Seite anlegen in der neuen Puffopedia, Community-MVP. Und zwar haben wir eine neue Puffopedia unter puffopedia.info. Puffopedia.de wird auch bald auf dieser Seite verlinken, aber da wird die Puffopedia neu aufgebaut. Wir versuchen, alle Artikel, die die ursprüngliche Puffopedia hatte, zu retten, alle Bilder, die ja gemalt wurden, alle lustigen Sachen, aber jetzt gilt es natürlich eine Menge nachzuholen, ungefähr so 17 Monate, die die Puffopedia zerbrochen auf dem Boden lag, gilt es jetzt wieder neu zum Leben zu erwecken. Und ihr seid herzlich eingeladen, auf Pufopedia.info neue Artikel zu erstellen. Wo ist der Artikel zum Boosted Board? Wo ist der Artikel zu Stephans neue Freundin? All das brauchen wir in der neuen Pufopedia. Ja, das finde ich nicht schlecht. Ganz kurz mal eben, ihr kommt mir nicht so einfach davon. Und zwar wegen der Blitzersache der letzte Woche. Ich habe was erklärt, eine steile These rausgehauen in letzter Woche und ich wurde mit Mails überschwemmt. Ich wurde mit Filmen überschwemmt zu diesem Thema Blitzer. Blitzer im Alltag. Und mir wurde vorgeworfen, falsch zu liegen und ... Leute, nope. 90 Folgen und sie verstehen es nicht. 90 Folgen und ich lag noch nicht so sehr.
90 Folgen und ich lag noch nicht einmal falsch. Blitzer, was ich sagen will, ihr habt gesagt, ja, und wenn man dann da geblitzt wird an einem Ort, wo vorher durchgesagt wurde, dass man langsamer fahren soll, hat das doch in den gleichen Ausgang, als wenn man eh schon langsamer fährt, weil man Angst hat, da könnte geblitzt werden. Nein, was ich sagen wollte, ist eigentlich diese These. Man sollte nie verraten, wo wir zerstehen, damit man potenziell überall denkt, geblitzt werden zu können. Ja, aber das tut man ja nicht effektiv, oder? Und das denkt effektiv nicht, aber rein praktisch, äh, theoretisch. Ja. Rein in meinem Kopf! In dem Moment, wo man die Blitzeranzahl erhöht und man das Gefühl hat, dass man theoretisch überall geblitzt werden könnte. Ist auch wichtig, wenn du steuern willst, dass du ab und zu deinem Sprechtempo ins Unermessliche steigerst. Wenn du irgendwann das Gefühl hast und Pause machen, das effektiv die Anzahl dermittelkosten eigentlich, dann fährt man überall langsamer, das ist meine These. Deswegen, in dem Moment, wo du ein Bildstander Auto verrätst, begrenzt du die Vorsicht des Langsamfahrens auf diese Orte. Das ist so, das ist so, Leute, es macht auch gar keinen Sinn, darüber zu diskutieren. Ich bin da mit dem Mikro, das ist gerade ein guter Vorteil. Ihr könnt gerade euren Kühlschrank anschreien, aber niemand wird euch hören. Das war der Stefan-Titzer-Automobil-Check. Ich habe letztens viel über Edward Snowden nachgedacht. Zu viel für meinen Geschmack. Ja, es war vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel. Weil ich weiß nicht, was der Typ so treibt momentan. Der ist ja in Russland, hängt der rum und das ist ja wirklich wie so, weil man denkt sich ja oft so, so ein Film, man schaut sich ja gerne Filme an, so coole Geschichten von coolen Typen, aber Filme hören irgendwann auf.
So, die Geschichte ist erzählt, jeder kennt den Klassener Story-Arcs, so, es passiert irgendwas, dann gibt's ein Problem, dem Held werden Steine in den Weg gelehrt, dann muss der Held irgendwie Lektionen lernen, dann irgendwann muss er seine eigene Vergangenheit überwinden, bla bla bla und irgendwann schafft er dann sein großes Ziel, er hat dabei eine Lektion gelernt, muss sich auf irgendwie sich selber verlassen, muss sich von seinen Mentoren abkapseln, bla bla bla und dann ist die Geschichte vorbei. Und dann passiert nichts mehr. Was macht Legolas heute? Nichts. Nee, das stimmt nicht, er hat seinen Krebsstand aufgemacht irgendwo auf Ischgl. Die haben sich irgendwo so einen Einfamilienbaum geholt und wohnen da jetzt in so einem Elbenwald und leben da und machen gar nichts mehr. Aber zum Beispiel auch, stell dir mal vor, Titanic. Titanic und die werden nicht gegen den Eisberg gefahren. Und die beiden wären einfach angekommen und hätten sich ein Einfamilienhaus geholt und dann hieß es, ja, wir bringen jetzt den Müll raus. Und ja, irgendwie jetzt, keine Ahnung, wollen wir diese Woche nicht mal irgendwie endlich tanzen gehen? Nee, ich habe keine Zeit. Mega langweilig. Das ist perfekt. Das Beste, was ihrer Liebe passieren konnte, ist, dass sie beide sterben. In Love. In Love. Weil dann heißt der Höhepunkt. So, Edward Snowden ist für mich so eine Gimli-Figur, die, wenn Herr der Ring jetzt zu Ende erzählt ist, einfach jetzt noch weitergeht. Sauron ist besiegt, alle leben in Frieden. Gut, ist bei Snowden nicht ganz der Fall. Aber seine Geschichte... Er hat Sauron gewissermaßen erschaffen. Ja, aber schau dir mal, es gibt ja mittlerweile auch schon zwei Filme über Edward Snowden. Stell dir mal vor, du bist Edward Snowden und schaust diesen Film an und der Abspann läuft und du denkst dir, geil. Geil, cooler Typ. Und dann guckst du in deine eigene Wohnung und denkst dir, ja und jetzt? Ich bin jetzt... Teil zwei, komm on, Teil zwei. Ich nach diesem Abspann, nichts mehr passiert. Was willst du noch? Auch der weisse Hai, diese Strandbar, die wird sich doch auch nicht durchsetzen. Auf keinen Fall. Wie traurig ist es denn, wenn die alle kämpfen und dann geht die Strandbar pleite, weil dann doch irgendwie niemand Lust hat auf diese Drinks mit der Ananassscheibe drin. Ja, vor allem nach so einem Haiangriff da, gut, haben die den Hai besiegt, aber der Strandgewinn hat das Vertrauen nicht mehr zurück. Der ist gelaufen, die Nummer. Das stimmt, das ist ein guter Punkt. Ja, vor allem stell dir vor, Edward Snowden, keine Ahnung, hat jetzt mal Bock, der hat ja auch Hobbys, das ist ja ein normaler Mensch. Also so, der hat ja irgendwie zum Beispiel, der ist irgendwie jetzt, keine Ahnung, der sammelt Modelleisenbahnen und sagt sich, geil, ich mache jetzt einen Podcast über Modelleisenbau und so die neuesten Releases, ich gehe auf so eine Messe in Russland, schau mir das an, sprich vielleicht mit den besten Sammlern so über legendäre, du kannst doch nicht dir einen Podcast anhören von Edward Snowden, der über Modelleisenbau redet, so der kann doch nichts mehr machen, das wird doch nicht ernst genommen werden. Nee, aber auch er selber kann sich, es ist ein Film über dich und du krass Leute applaudieren und wow, du hast grosse Sachen vollbracht, die die Welt verändern und dann gehst du plötzlich, setzt dich hin und denkst, okay, das war jetzt der Film über mich und gehst über zu deinem Hobby, dass du jetzt anfängst, Flugzeuge zu bemalen. So wo du auch denkst, soll ich das sein? Ich liebe gerade das, was aus dem Film rausgeschnitten wurde, weil es kein Schwein interessiert. Hat man nicht dann auch das Bedürfnis an sich selber, Dinge zu machen, die wieder verfilmbar sind? Also, oder nicht? Also wenn jetzt ein Film über dich gemacht wird und dann ist der vorbei, dann willst du doch gewissermaßen Teil zwei vorleben. Ja, das ist, ich stelle mir immer so die Frage, so, wie hat sich Tarantino gefühlt, nachdem er Pulp Fiction fertig war? Hat er sich gedacht, geil, mein Leben ist bereits jetzt zu Ende, ich muss nichts mehr leisten, ich habe alles schon erreicht, ich habe kein schlechtes Gewissen mehr, das ist wie wenn du früher von der Schule heimgekommen bist und du dachtest, okay, ich habe den Tag wirklich rein frei, sowas haben wir nicht mehr, sowas gibt es nicht mehr, weil man immer denkt, ich muss noch das machen, habe ich selber gemerkt, ich muss mich noch in meinem PayPal Steuern, ah meinerkt. Ich muss mich noch in meinem PayPal-Account. Steuern. Oh mein Gott. Ich muss mich noch in meinem PayPal-Account. Was sind Steuern? Ich wollte mal wieder eine neue Bar. Sie sind im Knast. Ich will das ausreißen. Für mich waren das jetzt zehn Minuten Anekdote, die du gerade kaputt gemacht hast. Gut, da lag mehr Gag. Sorry, aber das sage ich dir jetzt. Wir haben 90 Folgen hinter uns. Bei Larke geht es gerade mehr drin. Diese Anekdote, die du gerade kaputt gemacht hast. Gut, da lag mehr Gag. Nein, aber es ist einfach so. Sorry, aber das sage ich dir jetzt, wir haben 90 Folgen hinter uns, bei Lark geht es gerade mehr drin. Diese Anekdote. Ja, dann mach was doch. Ja gut, ich glaube, unsere Zuschauer sind so erfahren, die können sich das auch selber decken. Die können das selber zusammenbauen. Solche Gags wie, wir geben nur Stichworte. Wofür bist du drin, Vergewaltigung, du, Mord und du, ich weiß nicht, was Steuern sind. Mir hat nie jemand gesagt, dass Steuern existieren. Aber dann sowas in der Richtung. Aber dieses Gefühl, wie Freitag, 17 Uhr, du bist von der Schule zu Hause und sagst, ich habe einfach tagelang nichts zu tun. Und ich glaube, so entweder... Das stimmt nicht ganz. Das gehört ich neulich, als ich mit der Uni fertig war. Übrigens... Dankeschön! Stefan Tietze, oder wie wir besser sagen sollten, Bachelor Stefan Tietze! Aber hast du die jetzt schon ... Du hast ja abgegeben. Ja, ja, abgegeben, auch bestanden quasi. Ach geil, er hat sich Glückwunsch. Weiß ich nicht, weiß ich nicht. Aber ich bin quasi jetzt durch, und da bin ich in so ein kleines Loch gefallen. Da dachte ich dann ganz kurz, okay, jetzt ist nur noch Comedy in meinem Leben. Ist das ein Leben? Wo ich mir manchmal auch denke, wir haben ja nicht so mega das gute Essensangebot in dieser Firma. Heißt, manchmal gehen wir dann nachmittags in Lidl und dann hole ich mir so Würsten aus dem Regal und gehe dann zur Kasse und denke mir, ist das jetzt eine Mahlzeit? Ist das jetzt das Essen? Kann man das Essen und dann ist das dein Mittagessen, das die Mahlzeit, die du isst? das habe ich ja auch so, ich habe ja nur, ohne das Studium habe ich nur so ein Comedy-Kram jetzt am Laufen, wo ich mir denke, ist das ein Leben? Würden das andere Menschen als Leben bezeichnen oder das, was Stefan halt da so macht? Lass den mal an seinem Kindertisch leben. Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein vollwertiges Leben ist und deswegen dachte ich kurz, okay, ich bin ein Loch gefallen, aber eigentlich ist es ein ziemlich gutes Loch, so ein wohliges Loch. Ja, aber es ist die Frage, entweder du denkst dir dann, jetzt muss das nächste große Ding kommen, oder du denkst dir einfach so, ja jetzt scheißegal, keine Ahnung, du bist, stell dir vor, du bist Wagner, du hast deine Opern geschrieben, du bist ein Genie, niemand hat mehr Erwartungen an dich. Also ich glaube, niemand, der diese Haltung vertritt, hat jemals was geleistet. Nachdem man was geleistet hat? Never.
Meinst du?
Nein. Also Quentin Tarantino hätte Pulp Fiction nie gemacht, wenn er, als er Pulp Fiction gemacht hätte, die Haltung vertreten hat, das ist jetzt das Beste, was ich gemacht habe. Niemand, der so an den Film rangeht, so perfektionistisch ist, würde jemals behaupten, der Film ist das Beste, was sich erreichen kann. Ich würde vor allem auch die Frage in den Raum werfen, ob Pulp Fiction nicht nur deswegen so gut ist, weil Quentin Tarantino weiter Filme gemacht hat. Wer hätte denn nach Pulp Fiction aufgehört, wäre das vielleicht nie so ein Kultfilm geworden. Meine Theorie vielleicht. Einfach dadurch, dass der Name Quentin Tarantino so und auch neue Zuschauerschaften jetzt halt immer wieder so getrichtert werden auf Pulp Fiction, das ist der beste Film aller Zeiten, so darauf kommen, hätte es aufgehört, kann sein, dass der in der Versenkung verschwunden wäre.
Du hättest ja nie dein Poster aufgehängt in deiner Scheiß-Studentenbude, wenn du nicht in Glorious Barsitz im Alter von 18 als ersten Tarantino-Film gesehen hättest und sagst, ja gar, ich bin jetzt Death-to-Fan. Ich weiss nicht, warum jetzt hier jemand in einem Rand rennt, aber ich finde die Formulierung gerade fand ich lustig, eine Frage in den Raum werfen, weil es immer so ein bisschen, stell dir das mal vor, wie jemand eine Frage in den Raum werft. Das klingt, finde ich, als ob man so eine Granate, die so entschärft, in den Raum wirft und dann sich in Deckung bringt. Aber es sind Leute, die die Fragen in den Raum werfen, ja eher eigentlich Leute, die eigentlich den Raum geben, weil sie ja eigentlich selber am meisten mitreden wollen. Okay.
Comedy, comedy, comedy, comedy, comedy.
Also, Edward Snowden, falls du zuhörst, ich würde mir deinen Podcast anregen, egal was du machst.
Aber alle würden, das wäre für mich, weil wir sind ja auch, also kann man auch mal ehrlich sein,
wir sind ja Menschen, wir leiden auch ein bisschen unter unseren eigenen Images und unter unseren Running Gags. Ja. Wir können eigentlich nichts mehr, letztens hast du einen richtig guten Tweet rausgehauen, der mega viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommen hat, über 2000 Likes auf Twitter mega gut und die Hälfte der Kommentare darunter waren Fehlkauf, Fehlkauf, Fehlkauf, Fehlkauf. Obwohl in dem Tweet nicht der Hauch eines Fehlkaufs Gags drin war. Aber egal was du machst, die Leute sofort Fehlkaufsteffen, Fehlkaufsteffen, Fehlkauf, Fehlkauf, Fehlkauf. Obwohl in dem Tweet nicht der Hauch eines Fehlkaufs-Gags drin war. Aber egal was du machst, die Leute sofort Fehlkauf, Stefan, Fehlkauf, Stefan, Fehlkauf, Stefan. Und da kann man sich ja denken, okay, man ist dann schon so ein bisschen verflucht von seinem eigenen Erfolg oder seiner eigenen Persona, sowas in der Richtung. Und das wäre bei Snowden genau dasselbe. Wenn der jetzt ein Kochbuch rausbringt, würden auch alle so Prism-Gags machen. Aber ist das ist das nicht auch was für einen Anteil? Betrachte das doch jetzt einfach mal separat. Ein Mensch ist facettenreicher als nur ein Ding. Ich glaube, also in dem Moment, wo Leute dich so wahrnehmen, wie du willst, hörst du, glaube ich, auf. Und ich glaube, dass auch ein Tarantino das aufregt, wenn Leute sagen, boah, das mit dem Koffer, das ist doch bestimmt stellvertretend für die Seele, oder da ist doch irgendwas drin, die Kombination war natürlich sechs, sechs, sechs und so, dass er denkt, fuck you, scheiß auf den Kack-Koffer, das war lustig, ich fand die Idee cool, dass da Licht rauskommt, wow, er fokussiert sich bei den anderen coolen Dialoge und so einen Scheiss. Und in dem Moment, glaube ich, hast du auch Bock, dann andere Dinge zu machen, die wiederum ernst genommen werden oder so wahrgenommen werden, wie du es willst. Ja, auf der anderen Seite fällt man ja auch selber in dieses Loch. Ich finde zum Beispiel, eine der tragischsten Figuren der Menschheitsgeschichte ist George Lucas. Einfach weil der, wir haben letztens darüber gesprochen, hat er ... Guck ich unbedingt diese Dokumentation an, The People vs. George Lucas. Auf jeden Fall, wo es darum geht, dass die ersten drei Filme mega gehypt wurden und die neue Trilogie total gehasst wurde und die Leute wütend auf George Lucas war. Von Twilight. Ja, und das ist so ein bisschen das Ding, weil man ja selber auch die neue Trilogie, eins, zwei, drei, nicht einfach für sich betrachtet, sondern immer sagt, früher war die Macht cooler und Yoda war viel cooler als jetzt Qui-Gon Jinn, wurden Midi-Chlorian und nene, nene, nene. So betrachtet es ja auch nicht neu irgendwie so. Und ich glaube, George Lucas ist so stellvertretend fürend für jemanden der sich wirklich denken muss so ich bin berühmt geworden für etwas, das ich eigentlich vielleicht gar nicht so gemeint habe oder das eigentlich eher nur unter falschen Protektionsverständnissen oder so, das was ich wirklich möchte, erreichen wollte, hassen die Leute aber das was ich so früher mal gemacht habe, das nehmen die Leute das ist echt eine tragische Figur. Ich glaube, der hatte die beste Zeit
seines Lebens bei den Prequels.
Wir merken doch auch...
Da weiß ich nicht, ob ich dir da recht geben soll.
Okay, aber wir merken doch auch in unserem kreativen Arbeiten,
dass sobald Leute einem reinreden,
man es hasst.
Auch wenn es einen, wenn man immer ehrlich ist,
immer voranbringt, immer.
Auch wenn man sich selber nochmal hinterfragt
und dann nochmal klarer fasst den Gedanken vielleicht. Eig, eigentlich hilft es oft, aber man hasst es, weil man das gewissermaßen, auch irgendwann, wenn du selbstbewusst genug bist, als die beste Idee für dich siehst, die du dann in den Raum stellst. Und ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen das Problem. In dem Moment, wo er einfach nur noch Ja-Sage um sich herum hatte und alles machen konnte, weil ihm Leute alles geglaubt haben und alles abgekauft haben.
Und Productionsfilm einfach froh waren, George Lucas zu haben, der diesen Weltkulturerbe dahingestellt hat. Glaube ich, hat er einfach die beste Zeit seines Lebens, weil er machen konnte, was er wollte. Ja, aber vielleicht ist das auch der Fluch, dass sobald du merkst, oh, in dem Moment, in dem ich machen kann, was ich will, wird es richtig scheiße. Ja, ja, aber das kann man danach. Das ist, glaube ich, eine sehr verheerende Erkenntnis, dass du merkst, so, eigentlich, es liegt gar nicht an mir, sondern vielleicht, ich haue raus und andere Leute machen dann was Cooles draus oder so. Ich glaube, man kann nie sein eigenes Talent oder seine Leistung wirklich so begreifen. Diese geile Szene, wo die dann zum ersten Mal im Screening sitzen und dann gibt es halt diese geile Reaktion von Episode 1, wie die dann am Ende da sitzen und halt einfach nichts sagen und sich einfach nur so angucken. Drei erwachsene, grauhaarige Menschen, die einfach so in den Händen versinken und sagen, ja, this Jar Jar character doesn't work. Nope, that's work. Ja, und George Lucas auch meint so, ich bin vielleicht an manchen Stellen ein bisschen zu weit gegangen. Ja, aber stimmt, ja. Mach du mal ein Sketch ganz alleine und ich glaube, alle hätten die gleiche Reaktion. Wie, alle hätten die gleiche Reaktion? Dass es nicht gut ist, dass man sich verrannt hat? Ja, ich glaube, man verrannt immer automatisch ein bisschen. Das hat Aaron Salkin auch mal gesagt, dass sobald er, weil bei seinen Serien hat auch niemand mehr Bock mehr Bock die ganze Zeit hinterher zu gucken und so. Oft ist es der erste Draft, der für eine Serie dann auch einfach gedreht wird, wo er dann oft denkt, oh shit, das war vielleicht doch nicht so gut, ich bin vielleicht ein bisschen zu weit gegangen. Sobald die George Lucas Autobiografie rauskommt, ey, das ist meine Bibel, ich will das einfach wissen. Diese Person ist auch so undurchdringbar. Man weiß nicht, ist der komplett fake, ist der komplett crazy? Der hat diesen lustigen Körperbau, der hat diesen Kopf und seine Haare sehen erstens exakt so aus wie sein Bart, sieht einfach aus wie gedreht und dann hat er diesen keinen Hals, sondern einfach so eine geschwülst, so einen großen, so einen großen Ball wie so ein Kugelfisch oder wie dieser Charakter aus Episode 1. Nichts ist ein grosser Naboo-Verbündeter, der Typ, ich weiß nicht, wie der heißt. Ich weiß auch nicht, aber es gibt eine geniale YouTube-Videoreihe von einem sehr großen Star-Wars-Fan, der sich zum Auftrag gemacht hat, viele Nebendarsteller aus Episode 1, Anakin zum Beispiel oder auch Boss, wie heißt der Boss, Boss, Boss, Boss, Boss, Boss, Boss heisst er. Auch solche Leute zu interviewen über ihr Erlebnis und auch den Jaja-Schauspiel, was richtig interessant ist, den zu interviewen, schaut da gerne mal rein, ist auf jeden Fall interessant. und wo auch dieser Boss-Nass-Typ interviewt wurde, der auch einfach
sich selber ausgedacht hat mit diesem
Mundrumschlackern irgendwie, und man
so wie er der Typ ist, wo einfach
so ganz merkwürdige Leute zusammenkamen für diese
Episode 1, also ganz komisch.
Und Hugh McGregor mittendrin und Natalie Portman
irgendwie, ganz merkwürdig. Was dachten die denn,
was da um sie herum passiert? So,
oh mein Gott, da ist ein Typ, der einfach die ganze
Zeit falsch spricht, wow, da ist die ganze Zeit so ein Typ, der mit so einem großen Ball am Hals. Hier ist ein kleines achtjähriges Kind. Okay. Der überhaupt nicht spielen kann. Oh mein Gott. Was für ein furchtbarer... Na gut. Was cool wäre so ein Star-Wars-Podcast, wo man nur über Star Wars redet. Das wäre cool. Das wäre echt cool, aber auch ein bisschen resonant. Und ich würde diesem Podcast rasten, nie eine Folge über Kashyyyk zu machen. Eine ganze Folge. Wäre eine dumme Idee. Du meinst den Planet, wo die Rookies leben? Ja. Und wo dann alles drüber gesagt ist nach diesem einen Satz? Ja. Ich war gestern in einem Fotofix. Ich war gestern für meinen Personalausweis, für meinen Reisepass, der abgelaufen ist. Übrigens, weil ich bei der Star Wars Celebration in Orlando dabei bin. Ja. Wie gross ist das denn eigentlich? Und dafür brauche ich einen Reisepass. Und da war ich gestern in so einem Fotofix. Und unscheinlich, wir sind im Jahre 2017. Leute dachten vor hundert Jahren, dass es mittlerweile Raumschiffe gibt und so. Man ist in diesem versifften, versifften scheiß kleinen Dixie-Clo-ähnlichen Gebilde, wo man so einen Vorhang hat, der nicht bis zum Boden reicht, weil das hat nicht gereicht, das Geld offenbar. Das wäre zu teuer gewesen. Dann sitze ich da und ein Kollege von mir, der mit war, hat ein Foto davon gemacht und ich will gerne mal sehen, wie es aussieht. Tarkan war mit und hat ein Foto davon gemacht. In der U-Bahn war das vor allem. Dein Kopf schaut oben raus. Das ist so im U-Bahn-Betrieb, Leute laufen da rum in der Bierflasche, haben eine coole Zeit und ich sitze da, hinten zu einem kleinen Vorhang, der so bis zu meinen Schultern geht und darunter sieht man einfach meinen Körper, dass er sitzt und ein Foto von sich machen lassen muss. Und das ist einfach, die Wand hinter mir ist dreckig und das ist jetzt das Foto, was man sieht von mir, immer auf Reisepass, wo Leute, wenn man im fremden Land ankommt, das Erste, was sie sehen, ist dieses Bild und dann gucken sie dich an und lachen, weil sie sich dann nachher lustig finden, weil der in der Sprache eine Beleidigung ist. Weißt du, was richtig Spaß macht, mit seinen besten Freunden in so eine Fotobox zu gehen und so lustige Bilder zu machen? Das ist super lustig, oder? Nichts macht mehr Spaß auf der Welt. Das ist total lustig. Ich habe das Gefühl, man hatte keinen Spaß, wenn man nicht das einmal gemacht hat in seinem Leben. Ja, und ich habe das Gefühl, das hat man mal verfil Film, in so einer Collage stelle ich mir das vor. Oder vielleicht so ein Pärchen, das sich gerade getrennt hat und dann einer der beiden nochmal so diese Vier-Bilder-Reihe rausholt, wo die dann im vierten Bild noch so einen lustigen Hut aufhaben oder sowas. Das wäre so lustig. Das wäre echt eine gute Szene. Und dann guckt er sich so verweint um und sieht diesen Hut im Regal. Wie gut wäre das denn eigentlich? Das wäre richtig lustig. Und dann schält sie, weil sie noch was vergessen hat in der Wohnung. Oder klingelt, je nachdem. Das taktische Trinken mit Stefan Tietze. Tietze. Ja, stimmt, Tietze. Du warst beim Scheiterhaufen-Podcast zu Gast. Ja, ich war beim Scheiterhaufen-Podcast. Hört mal rein, Scheiterhaufen. Von unserem Redakteur Jan Horst, unser zuständiger ZDF-Redakteur. Und Stefan redet über das Scheitern. Ich rede darüber, aber eine kurze Folge, oder? Und du bist heute im Podcast-Burrito zu Gast. Ja, ist richtig. Ich bin heute im Podcast-Burrito zu Gast. Ich freue mich sehr. Wenn die Folge online kommt, dürfte die Folge vielleicht schon online sein, keine Ahnung, wie die dir. Weißt du, beim Podcast-Burrito, das ist ja immer so, da fragt man sich, wie läuft das, ne? Wann veröffentlichen die genau, wann nehmen die auf? Das das ist ja noch so ein Mysterium irgendwie so, nicht so wie bei uns, die wir alles transparent gemacht haben, einfach irgendwie unserer Seele den Mainstream geopfert haben. Nee, beim Podcast Burrito, die machen noch richtig gute Podcast-Indie-Kost. Ich glaube, wenn die gut werden, also nicht, dass die noch nicht gut werden, aber wenn die richtig gut werden, hören wir auf. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das sind nämlich die, die uns irgendwann ablösen, die kriegen auch immer ein Mikrofon, was überreiche ich denen so? Oh ja. Weil wenn du aufhörst, Podcaster zu sein, dann musst du auch so eine Marke abgeben und so ein Mikrofon. Ja. Du musst einfach so, das ist getan Arbeit. Das war's dann. Hast du schon mal was an die Wand gehängt? An den Nagel gehängt, meine ich? Deine Band oder deine Musikerkarriere? Ach so meinst du das? Ja, Musikerkarriere würde ich schon sagen, ja. Die habe ich an den Nagel gehangen. Auch ein komischer Ausdruck, aber eigentlich der normalste Ausdruck der Welt. Vielleicht hat man früher einfach so Nägel an der Wand und hat seinen Mantel genommen und an den Nagel gehangen und dann war die Arbeit getan, oder? Kommt das daher? Ist das so einfach? Ist das nicht so einfach? Ja, oder halt so als Memorabilium, dass man es halt nochmal anschaut, wenn man damit abgeschlossen hat. So wie ein Bild, man hängt es an die Wand. Keine Ahnung. Ich habe meine Gesangskarriere komplett an den Nagel gehangen. Ja? Du kannst auch nicht mehr singen, oder? Überhaupt nicht mehr. Gar nicht mehr? Komplett verloren. Aber ich finde immer, wenn wir irgendwie auch so ironisch irgendwie mal so ein Lied anstimmen, Stephans Engelgleiche Hafenstimme ist immer erkennbar, weil sie einfach butterweich die Töne trifft. Wir vor allem haben Happy Birthday perfektioniert, muss man heute sagen.
Kollege, heute Geburtstag.
Happy Birthday to you, happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you, happy birthday, lieber Sebastian, Pauline, Happy Birthday to you! Das Klatschen auch. Am Ende immer, ja. Aber ich finde, diesen einen Part den nehmen wir mittlerweile ganz gut, diese Zweistimmigkeit. Aber das müssen wir eigentlich den ganzen Tag durchkriegen. Wenn dieses Klatschen danach auch so, alle hassen das, aber alle machen es automatisch, weil es anscheinend dazugehört. Vor allem, ich glaube, wird dieses Ritual erweitern im Laufe der Zeit, irgendwann klatscht man und dann auch nochmal alle, hey! Und dann irgendwann klatschen alle und am Ende nochmal, hey, und dann geht es noch weiter, dann macht man so eine Bewege. Oh, wie schön das Du gewusst! Also es muss sich ja erweitern. Ich glaube, so fangen so Rituale an. So hat irgendwie Weihnachten angefangen, dass einer mal so einen Baum aufgestellt hat und dann haben alle angefangen zu singen,
dann haben irgendwie diese ausgeschnittenen Glanzteile an die Wand, ans Fenster gehängt und so ein Kram.
So entwickelt sich das langsam.
Ja, aber die ersten Leute, die das gemacht haben, waren Freaks.
Da hat man auch gesagt Freaks.
Aber mittlerweile sind das...
Heiden, nee, Weiden.
Heiden?
Nee, Weiden.
Weiden.
Scheiden.
Ungläubige heißen Heiden. Das war ein Scherz, den haben wir noch nie gemacht, so was. Ein bisschen unter der Gütel in den Scherz. Ich habe Bescheide gesagt. Das ist ein kleiner Scherz, der mal ein bisschen in eine andere Richtung führt, den ihr beim Podcast-Ufeln noch gar nicht so kennt. Viel Spaß mit dieser Humorrichtung. Um neuen Farbe. Ja, aber da frage ich mich oft, wie sowas entsteht. Auch das Konzept Nationalhymne finde ich so spannend.
Weil, gab es da mal eine Ausschreibung eigentlich, auch in Deutschland, oder? Das ist jetzt von Haydn. Oh, reimt dich sogar oft. Wie, es gibt eine Ausschreibung. Neue Nationalhymne? Nee, aber gab es das damals eine Ausschreibung? Ach so. Haydn hat das ja ge... Ey, aber ist das jetzt wieder so ein traditionalistisches Argument, aber man kann schon glücklich sein, dass die Nationalhymne damals geschrieben wurde, oder? Angenommen, die würde jetzt heute geschrieben werden, Ausschreibung an die besten Musiker Deutschlands, nichts gegen die Musiker Deutschlands, aber da kommt dann halt einfach mal so ein Save and I Do oder halt so ein Casper, die als Musiker völlig in Ordnung sind, aber Und die Chööre singen, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland. Oder würde man sich auch heute an klassische Musiker wenden? Das ist eine gute Frage. Weil das war ja damals Popmusik, klassische Musik. Das war das einzige, was es gab. Philipp Glas, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland. Ey, ich würde, ich finde es so schade, dass Philipp Glas so unbekannt ist. Ich würde so gerne mehr Gags über den machen. So Philipp Glas am Frühstückstisch, Philipps Glas, wie war Philipp Glas in der Schule oder so was. Einfach so was in der Richtung, aber naja gut, das kennt sich nicht jeder so gut mit Musik aus. Ab nächste Woche im Eichen Store, Philipp Glascast. Fände ich eigentlich lustig, ja. Einen Namen finde ich gut. GlassCast. Aber zum Beispiel, es gibt ja, ich habe so eine Doku gesehen über die Bundeswehr, dass die so ein bisschen Problem haben, dass die so die Uncoolen sind. So in Afghanistan und Irak und so, oder wo die halt kämpfen und so ein Kram. Weißt du, die Amerikaner, die haben noch so ihre ganze, die fuchteln die Gewehre drum, so Drill-Routines, die sind 500 Jahre alt, so Ideen. Oder die Briten, die trinken Tee, die haben eine lange Tradition, die haben noch ihre Chants und ihre Sprüche und irgendwie coole traditionalistische Sachen. Alles, was du gerade bei den Briten aufgesagt hast, ist massiv uncool. Nee, aber es ist schon cool. Sprüche. Die haben so Nationalsteuers und die haben so coole Sachen und die haben irgendwie, wie man sich salutiert und wie man so Sprüche macht und dann so coole Slangbegriffe für Waffen und so. Ja, und bei Deutschland potenzielle Armokläufer, potenzielle Armokläufer, potenzielle Armokläufer. Erstens das und Deutschland hat keine Tradition, weil die halt einfach einfach keinen, nach Nazi einfach abhaken mussten. Wir fangen mal von vorne an und es ist schwer irgendwie cool zu werden, wenn du einfach keine Wurzeln hast und dann halt alle so komplett nur zweckorientiert so, ja, das ist Schwimmwesten und das ist die Schwimmwestenschlaufe. So, das ist nicht cool, weil das alles nur so zweckoptimiert ist. Jetzt, eigentlich sollte man mehr Geld reinbuttern, damit die Kuder wirken. Ja! Kudere, Kudere, Kudere, ja, Waffen vielleicht auch sogar, sodass man so mal, also die müssen ja nicht aussehen wie so Laserpistolen, also die müssen zumindest keine Laserschüsse ab, sondern, bin nicht okay, aber das muss aussehen wie Laserblaster. Aber das ist, finde ich, keine schlechte Frage, ob bei Heckler und Koch bei so Waffenfirmen nicht auch einer sitzt, so ein Designer, weil das sind ja auch Designer, der einfach sagt so, ja, okay, cool, 120 Schuss pro Minute, ich glaube, das sind keine Designer, ganz kurz mal, lass uns mal rüber, das ist nur funktional, glaube ich. glaube ich. Auch das ist ja Designer. Eine Kaffeemaschine hat ja auch funktionale Teile, das muss ja jemand gestalten. Kleid sich Designer im klassischen Sinne. Ja, aber Waffen doch nicht. Bundeswehr ist alles nichts. Ich glaube, da überfließt so ein bisschen die zwischen Ingenieur und Produktdesigner irgendwo, aber zwischendrin. Aber gibt es auch da eine Position, die sagt, okay, Waffen, aber lass es uns doch ein bisschen cool aussehen, ein bisschen zumindest, oder ist es wirklich völlig egal? Vor allem das Gefühl, dass du auch viel, also im Fußball ist ja auch so, dass oft Farben auch genommen werden, um Leute abzuschrecken. Ich meine, Rot ist natürlich einfach Torwärte, Torwärte, Keeper haben oft bunte Trikots an, Pinke, oder Rote, ja, um halt 1 zu 1, 1 gegen 1 zu L bedrohlicher zu wirken, einfach um aufzufallen. Das ist wirklich interessant. Und da denke ich mir, gerade doch im Krieg, in einer Kriegssituation, ist es doch wichtig, den Gegner einzuschüchtern. Ich meine, nichtdestotrotz spielt jeder Helikopter, der auf irgendwas zufliegt, spielt die Welt in Wilkürien. Und deswegen denke ich mir, warum nicht einfach die Waffen größer machen oder gefährlicher aussehen lassen? So einen kleinen Heikopf. Ich überlege gerade, ob die nicht vielleicht sogar die Waffen bewusst uncool machen, damit die nicht in so eine Waffen-Rambo-Romantik irgendwie kommen können, dass Leute extra zur Bundeswehr gehen, weil die die Uniformen so cool finden und so, sondern dass das extra so ein bisschen uncool wirkt.
Weil es immer im Ernst, so Wehrmachts-SS-Uniformen sahen richtig geil aus und heute ne, Mittel, so und auch die Waffen und die Helme ist alles nicht so cool und auch so, ich habe auch die Rekruten gesehen auf YouTube und dann haben die auch so Gewehre geschossen und dann müssen die in so eine ganz uncoole Hocke gehen, wenn die schießen, so warum kannst du nicht so cool so mit zwei MGs in jeder Hand dann so durch die Gegend reinlaufen, sondern es sieht alles so uncool aus und ich glaube, da ist Technik dahinter. Ich glaube, das ist ein Sinn, dass man Leute, die nur wegen Coolness gründen zur Bundeswehr gehen, das mit ihr abschreckt. Ich weiß, dieses Thema, da nerf ich viele Leute mit, die beschweren sich, wenn ich darüber spreche, Exoskelette. Ja, endlich, endlich spricht zwei jemand an. Exoskelette sind cool. Sie sehen immer, sie sehen mega cool aus und da ist doch auch bestimmt schon viel mehr möglich. Das ist auch nicht so teuer, aber das hat man halt nicht, weil es, glaube ich, zu cool ist einfach. Das sieht zu cool aus. Es gibt auch diese eine Werbung, wo Behinderte mit ihren ganzen Hilfsmitteln so auf Kinder treffen und die das dann so erklären, das haben wir bestimmt schon mal gesehen. Die, die Andy Badir geschnitten hat. Und da hat doch auch einer so Beine, so Roboterbeine, so Exoskelettbeine, mit der er durch die Gegend läuft.
Ich habe gestern auch mal jemandem erzählt, wow, wie cool ist es, wenn man keine Beine hat und dann einfach diese Prothesen bekommt und man einfach, das sieht einfach auch nicht aus, weil du trägst eine Hose darüber und wenn es keine enger liegende Hose ist, siehst du einfach normal aus und plötzlich läufst du einfach schnell los. wo mir zu Recht entgegnet wurde, ich glaube nicht, dass man dann schneller laufen kann unbedingt, aber ich finde schon auch höher springen oder so, diese Samuel-Koch-Dinger. Letztens haben wir erfahren, dass einer der Komparsen, mit dem wir schon gedreht haben bei Gute Arbeit, nur ein Bein hatte, aber eine Beinprothese getragen hat und ihr könnt jetzt einfach mal in die Kommentare schreiben, welcher der Komparsen aus den Gute-Arbeit-Videos ihr denkt, dass nur ein Bein hatte. Hä? Ja, tatsächlich. Ich habe letztens mitbekommen, dass einer der Komparsen nur ein Bein hatte, aber eine Prothese getragen und wir haben es nicht gemerkt. Wir haben den ganzen Tag mit ihm gedreht und man hat sich einen intensiven Kontakt mit Komparsen. Und er hat ganz normal gesprochen, vernünftige Ansichten. Auf jeden Fall, deswegen ist man da schon weit. Das sind normale Menschen, ey. Das sind ganz, wo wird es wirklich, wo wird es ich dachte, die werden, ja,ig. Ich dachte, das wird man den ansehen. So, wir brauchen auf jeden Fall einen Gewinner für unsere App. Ich bin für die Netflix-Dame. Zwanny. Oder wir teilen es auf, wie er ein Zehner. Warte mal, Netflix-Dame. Ich bin für die Netflix-Dame, die quasi das, wo man sieht, dass Leute in der Umgebung, weil Netflix und so, das personalisiert einen, das macht einen aber auch ein bisschen einsam. Das ist cool, wie individuell das ist, das ist cool, wie, dass man seine eigenen Serien gucken kann und halt du nicht auf das Programm anderer angewiesen bist. Und das ist alles cool, führt halt dazu, dass du oft alleine guckst und deswegen finde ich es ganz cool, so einen sozialen Aspekt zu dichten. Aber meinst du das würde gut funktionieren, wirklich, dass wenn du jetzt siehst, ah okay, da schaut jemand gerade Westworld Staffel 1 natürlich, oh, da klopfe ich mal an irgendwie mit einer Packung Merci und will jetzt da mitschauen irgendwie. Glaubst du, das funktioniert? Da versteht man sich? Der muss auch die App haben und sagen, ja, aber dann funktioniert es super, klar. Wenn du auch darauf fachst, ich finde das eine klasse Idee. Und man matcht sich aber nur mit Serien, nicht mit Profilen, sondern nur mit Serien. Ja, ich finde es auch mit Kino sogar geil. So, wer hat Bock heute Abend ins Kino zu gehen? Aber dann lieber alleine wahrscheinlich auch. Ja, vor allem dann klopfst du da an, so Blind Date-mäßig, hast dann irgendwie deine Ferreo-Rochet-Packung in der Hand und dann setzt man sich auf die Couch und schaut Serien, ohne in Worten miteinander zu reden. Kann ganz interessant sein. Ich glaube aber, die meisten gucken nicht Serien wie du und ich, sondern die meisten reden dabei und wollen dabei lästern.
Auf gar keinen Fall, das glaube ich nicht.
Das glaube ich auf jeden Fall.
Was?
Ja klar.
Nee.
Ich glaube, die meisten gucken.
Aber ey, nochmal zurück zu La La Land. Mein Kopf ist wieder explodiert vor der Dreistheit und Dummheit von manchen Menschen.
Neben mir saß eine Frau, die hat, während die Werbung lief, noch vor dem Kinofilm, haben natürlich alle im Saal geredet und gelacht und sich unterhalten und alles, während die Werbung lief, hat sie laut pscht gerufen, während der Werbung, hat natürlich niemand reagiert, irgendwie ist es natürlich ein bisschen leiser geworden, aber dann haben sie die Leute wieder weitergeredet, nur, die hat während der Werbung pscht gesagt, nur um während des Films die ganze Zeit selbst zu reden. What? Die ganze Zeit selbst zu reden. Und in La La Land gibt es diese eine Szene. Psst, ich liebe nie wer. Ja, wo Emma Stone in einem Restaurant ist und sich mit Leuten unterhält. Und diese Leute, mit denen sie sich unterhält, die unsympathisch sind. Da sagt einer so, ja, Kinos gehe ich ja nicht mehr, sind ja dreckig irgendwie so. Und laufen auch keine guten guten Filme mehr und die Leute reden ja die ganze Zeit und beschweren sich nur darüber, dass es zu warm und zu kalt ist. Ja, großer Lacher im Raum, hat sie nicht davon abgehalten, trotzdem noch weiterzureden. Endlich gibt's mal einen Film, in dem während dem Film angesprochen wird, dass es scheiße ist, im Film zu sprechen. Ja? Übrigens gibt's auch eine Szene, wo man an einem Kino, wo man an dieser Wand vorbeiläuft, diese berühmte Wand, ich weiß nicht mehr, die heißt, The Mirror heisst sie, glaube ich einfach, wo man in Los Angeles langläuft und dann siehst du halt die ganzen Schauspieler, auch Child Chaplin und so, in einem Kino sitzen, was dich anguckt. Mega cool. Auf jeden Fall, in dem Kino wird gesagt, dass es scheiße ist, im Kino zu reden, trotzdem hat die Frau weitergeredet und hat dann kurz vor Ende des Films noch gesagt, oh, ist aber echt schon ein bisschen warm hier, oder? Also hat wirklich genau die beiden Sachen, die in dem Film gesagt werden, Leute beschweren sich im Kino, dass es immer zu warm und zu kalt ist, und sie reden, genau das hat die Frau gemacht. Aber jetzt vermischt, glaube ich, ja, aber jetzt macht der Film Dinge, die er selber nicht gut findet, Leute machen Dinge im Kino, wo sie eigentlich, die sie eigentlich nicht gut finden, es vermischt sich Ironie und so. Leute, wir müssen mal wieder einen Ironiekurs machen. Ich hatte einen riesigen Knoten im Kopf. Ironie ist auch danach zu handeln, was man normalerweise machen würde. Und das damit zu brechen, aber dann auch nicht, also das muss auch zu Ende gedacht werden. Ironie, du kannst auch nicht Dinge ironisch machen, weil du die halt machst. Da haben wir schon mal gesprochen. Ja, und man braucht auch manchmal, ist es auch einfach cleverer, es einfach nicht zu kommentieren. La Alain kommentiert sich konstant selbst. Da gibt es die Szene, wo Emma Stone schreibt dann ihr Theaterstück und gibt es dann Ryan Gosling und Ryan Gosling sagt dann, ich finde es super, es ist total retro, es ist so ein bisschen nostalgisch, es ist ein bisschen straightforward, aber das ist ja total cool. Eins zu eins ist ja genau der Film. So, aber dann, dann sagt er, dann sagt er, ja, manchen wird es ja wahrscheinlich nicht gefallen, weil es so retro ist und dann sagt er, ist doch scheißegal, ist doch egal, was die anderen Leute denken, wenn du es cool findest, dann mach es. Genau das macht der Film aber nicht. Der Film entschuldigt sich in dem Moment dafür, dass er so retro und nostalgisch ist. Also er lobt sich selber dafür, dass er so wahnsinnig edgy ist, aber zieht das dann nicht durch, sondern er würde es ja einfach so machen und nicht kritisieren und nicht selber kommentieren. Tut mir leid, ich. Ich habe Bock auf ein Musicalfilm gemacht, habe den gemacht und es tut mir echt leid, wenn ich dich jetzt entschuldigt, irgendwie bereichert persönlich eingegriffen habe. Ja, ist kein Problem. Aber wehe, du bekommst einen Oscar für den Film. Aber Whiplash war doch okay. Whiplash war richtig geil, deswegen habe ich ihn auch richtig gefreut. Ey, ich war in einer Oper neulich nochmal und zwar hat dann hinter mir, und das ist das krasseste, was ich jemals erlebt habe, ich habe noch nie so viel Wut in mir gespürt, hat hinter mir jemand die Oper nachgesungen. Was? Und er hat die nicht einfach nur nachgesungen. Er offensichtlich, ich dachte mir erst mal so, Credits, cool, es ist schon krass, eine Oper auswendig zu kennen. Aber du hast ja oben halt, in der Oper hast du immer, der Text wird ja immer eingeblendet oben. Ja. Und komischerweise hat er nie zum ersten Mal gesungen, wenn eine Melodie neu aufkam, sondern oft die Wiederholungsteile, dann er ist angefangen zu singen, mit dem Text, der oben stand.
Komisch, er hat einfach nur gesungen, mitgesungen und ich war noch nie so wütend, ist aber einfach ein alter Opa hinter mir, der einfach Spaß daran hatte.
Hat er gut gesungen, also kann man denken, das war selber Sänger?
Er hat nicht mitgesungen einfach nur, er hat das für sich selber mitgesungen, weißt du, so her und her gesungen. Das war furchtbar. Ich habe das noch nie so etwas Schlimmes erlebt. Aber naja. Ey, man bräuchte sowas wie Kino nur alleine. Aber nicht jetzt irgendwie so Heimkino oder sowas, sondern so schon öffentlichen Raum, aber so mit so Kabinen oder sowas. Mit so grossen Sitzkissen. Wie so ein Pornokino. Ne, so grossen Sitzkissen und die auch lachen. Lachen finde ich wichtig im Kino, dass man zusammen lacht und zusammen, dass man auch mal jemanden schluchzen hört oder so.
Oder jemanden mal Ohnein rufen hört.
Oder in so einer Schule wie bei einer Ex, dass man so Wände zwischen den Schülern baut, so sowas. Dass du so Wände aufbauen kannst zwischen Leuten. Ja, das finde ich nicht schlecht. So ein Plexiglas hochfahren lassen kannst. Ich glaube, irgendwann mal, wenn ich reich und berühmt bin, kaufe ich mir ein Kino, nur um selber neben der Leinwand zu sitzen, wie auf so einem Tennisplatz, so einem Tennis-Schiedsrichter auf so einem hohen Stuhl und mit einer Super-Soker in der Hand und mit so einer Nachtsichtbrille und dann einfach jeder, der während des Films spricht, kriegt direkt ein Schrei Wasser ins Gesicht, sofort. Und das ist dann mein Kino. Und Wasser steht gerade sprichwörtlich für Säure, was ihr dann in eurem Gesicht habt. Ich glaube, Leute würden gutes Geld zahlen, um in ein Kino zu gehen, wo sie die Garantie bekommen, dass niemand seinen fucking Maul aufmacht, während der Film läuft. Weil es gibt keinen Grund zu reden. Ich finde aber noch besser als so Wände, dass zwischen wären Wände, die man hochfahren kann, mit diesem Blick, was manchmal so Limousinenfahrer haben, Taxifahrer haben. So, dann geht man langsam hoch und man hört diesen nach unten Guckblick, wo man die Augen so zu Schlitzen macht und denkt, ja, ist mir scheißegal, ist mir scheißegal, und langsam so eine Wand hochfährt. Das ist cool, das braucht man.
Ja, Leute, also ich würde sagen, herzlichen Glückwunsch an Laura, die Gewinnerin unserer App-Ausschreibung für diese fantastische Idee von Ned Flinder. Vielen Dank an Laura, schreib uns, du wirst wahrscheinlich wissen, wer du bist, schreib am besten einfach nochmal eine Mail an uns und gib uns deine Konto-Daten durch, dann kriegen die, oder gib uns am besten eine Adresse, wir würden dir gerne den Original-20-Euro-Schein schicken. Den unterschreiben wir auch.
Und du kriegst noch einen Sticker dazu. Vielen Dank, herzlichen Glückwunsch, Laura, und natürlich vielen Dank an alle, die ihre App-Ideen eingeschickt haben.
Vielen Dank, alle, die uns hören.
Die können dir trotzdem noch an Google schicken und vielleicht werden die entwickelt. Ansonsten, macht's gut.
Macht euch aber keine Hoffnung. Schöne Woche noch.
Bis nächstes Mal.
Wir heben ab.
Macht's gut.
Tschüss.